hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
same tree so i'm going to upload this on
a friday so today we're going to be
doing an easy-ish problem
so we're given the root of two binary
trees p
and q we need to write a function to
check if they
are the exact same tree or not we can
determine that by
one making sure that the structure is
the exact same
so for example basically the number of
nodes right like they both have a root
node
they both have a left child and they
both have a right child right the
structure is the same
not only that though they also have to
have the exact same
values at every node position so in this
case we can see
they have the same value once again same
value in the left side
and lastly same value on the right side
so these are the exact same tree right
so
we can return true now if i got rid of
one of these nodes right
let's say i just got rid of this then
it's definitely not the same tree right
or
if i took this value and changed it
let's say to a
hunt a 10 or whatever then it's also not
the same tree because the values in this
case
are different right the main thing to
notice with this problem is it
lends itself very well to recursion and
we know that there's a
pretty convenient uh recurs recursive
way to traverse
trees and that's depth first search
we're going to be using that recursive
uh function to solve this problem so
remember we're trying to check if these
are the same
tree right so that's a big problem we're
comparing
the big trees can we break that down
recursively well first thing to
intuitively check is
we really just need to check the root
nodes right are these the same that's
the first thing to check
are the root nodes the same if they are
we're going to continue the function now
if they were different for example maybe
this had a different value if it was
true
we immediately return false right if
even a single node
doesn't match we can return false
nothing more is needed now if they do
match right these are equal great now
this is the recursive part we don't have
to consider this node anymore and we
don't have to consider this node anymore
and now we have changed the problem now
we actually have
two trees left we have one left sub tree
right these are the left sub trees and
we also have two
right sub trees so this is the right
subtree of the first
tree and this is the second right
subtree so now
the problem is change now we're checking
are these two trees
the exact same and are these two trees
the exact same right so we've changed
the problem
it becomes recursive right we're now
going to be looking at the sub trees
comparing them
now both of the sub trees need to be
equal right these two need to be equal
and these two need to be equal and then
we can return true
and we're just going to continue to
break this down obviously the tree
could be much larger than this in which
case we would continue to do that
now let's not consider this example
anymore we know with recursive functions
the
the main thing to consider is the base
case so what are a couple base cases
well what if we had
two null nodes right they're both empty
what's what's what are we going to
return then is this the same tree or is
this not the same tree well they're both
empty right so that's technically the
same tree in this base case
we return true what if the left
tree is null but maybe the right tree
has a single node in it
now this is obviously going to be false
right these are not the same tree and
the exact same thing could be true we
could have
a null in the right tree and a real node
in the left tree and that would also be
false
now the case where both nodes are
non-null
then we're going to be looking at the
values obviously if the values are the
same
that's true right that we're going to be
returning true they're the same tree
if the values are different we're going
to be returning false so
these are basically all of the base
cases that i went over
and the code is just basically going to
be implementing exactly what we just
showed right now so let's jump into that
oh and last but not least
the time complexity of this so the time
complexity is overall going to be
basically the size of both trees added
together so the size of p
plus q because worst case we would have
to iterate through every single node
in both trees so that's basically the
overall time complexity
so like i said this is going to be a
recursive function since we already went
through most of the base cases this is
going to be pretty easy peasy so
if you know debt first search already we
know the base case is important
so if the first tree is empty and if the
second tree is empty so
if p and q are empty then what are we
gonna do
we're gonna return true because they're
both empty trees empty trees are
technically equal
now if they're both not empty but maybe
one of them
is empty so if this this statement did
not execute
then we're going to go to the next one
so if not p or
not q the only thing difference between
this and the one above is this one is
and this one is or so if this one did
not
execute that means both of them are not
null but if
this executes that means only one of
them
is null now what happens if one of them
is null but the other one is
not null well then they're not the same
tree right so we're going to have to
return false in that case
and we had one more base case right so
let's say if neither of these statements
executes
that means that both of the trees are
non-empty so
now we can actually look at the values
so if p dot
val is not equal to q dot val
what does that tell us that tells us
that the values are not the same so the
trees are not the same
so we can return false in this case
one thing to notice here is that both of
these two
are executing the exact same thing right
this is returning false
and this is returning false so we can
actually condense this i'm going to copy
and paste this here so if
if this is true or if
this last thing is true then we can also
return false we don't actually need
this third condition so if this
statement does not execute
that means that both of the nodes p and
q
are not are are non-empty right and the
values are actually the same
because if this does not execute so then
what are we going to do over here now
we're going to do the recursive step
we're going to call is same tree
on the left and right subtree so if p
we're going to call it on p left and q
left
and we're going to call it on p right
and q right and what do we
want to know from for the when we're
comparing the left tree
and the right trees what do we want to
know we want to know that both
of the the left sub trees and the right
sub trees
are equal so we want this to be true and
we want this to return true as well so
we're gonna take
these two uh the return values of these
two function calls and we're gonna
and them together and if the and is true
we're gonna return true if the and is
false
we're gonna end up returning false and
this is the recursive step
this is the only thing that we have to
return this is the entire
function so this is a pretty good
problem to practice your tree traversals
your debt for search
practicing so i think it's a pretty good
problem
and i hope that this was helpful i hope
you do understand the edge cases and how
we simplified the code
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel
a lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon thank you so much for watching